- Hi, everyone, this is Priya Natarajan,
the current director of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities at Yale.
I'm absolutely delighted to
invite you all
to our convening and distinguished
speaker series today.
And the title of the talk
today is A Better Planet:
40 Big Ideas for a Sustainable Future.
But before I tell you about
our distinguished guest,
let me start by thanking our benefactors,
Richard and Barbara Franke,
for their generosity
in funding this program that enables
all the exciting activities
that we are able to do.
And I'm really grateful that you know,
our activities are such
up in such a format
that in this moment of pandemic disarray,
we are able to continue.
And I am very sorry that
we are not able to offer
the wonderful receptions,
in-person receptions,
the food and drink that go with
the celebratory atmosphere.
But however,
we are going to make do with
intellectual excitement.
So first I need,
all of you who are assembled
that we are recording this event,
and that all participants must
therefore mute their videos,
'cause then we would have to get
individual permissions and so on.
So kindly mute your videos.
Wish you could submit talks
through the chat feature.
This is the process we
followed previously.
And
Ty will help us moderate this
and thank you so much Ty for doing that.
So,
our speaker today, I'm
thrilled to introduce
one of our own distinguished
faculty members,
Professor Dan Esty.
Dan Esty is the Hillhouse
Professor at Yale University
with primary appointments
at Yale's Environmental
and Law schools and a
secondary appointment
at the Yale School of Management.
He currently serves as the director
of the Yale Center for
Environmental Law and Policy,
co-director of the Yale
Initiative on Sustainable Finance.
Current research and writing
offer cutting-edge thinking
about climate change,
sustainable investing,
innovation in the energy
environment context.
And of course, matters of
corporate sustainability,
and brand new approaches,
radical new approaches to
environmental protection.
He's a pioneering thinker
in helping us reshape
how we should think about climate change
and how to alleviate it.
He is the author and editor
or editor of 12 books
and dozens of articles on
environmental protection,
regulatory reform, energy policy
and sustainability metrics
and their connections
to corporate strategy competitiveness.
So very much rooted in the
policy in the real world.
He had a prize winning,
he's had many prize winning books.
His latest book, a 2019 book,
in which he has edited a
wonderful set of essays.
And I would like to highly recommend that.
I thoroughly enjoyed reading it.
And Dan just mentioned that
it's just come out in paperback.
So I really urge you all
to buy it and read it.
So this book was just awarded
the Financial ft Book of the Year Award
and his previous prize winning
volume was "Green to Gold:
How Smart Companies Use
Environmental Strategy to Innovate,
Create Value, and Build
Competitive Advantage".
And this has recently been named
one of the top green business
books of the past decade.
And he has had many interesting articles.
I would like to point one out that I think
was particularly impactful for me,
"Red Lights to Green Lights:
From 20th Century Environmental Regulation
to 21st Century Sustainability".
So I wanted to say a little
bit about his career trajectory
only because of how distinguished it is
and how varied it is.
And it gives you a sense of someone
who really crosses
disciplinary boundaries.
That is a hallmark of what we celebrate
at the Franke Program.
From 2011 to 2014, Professor Esty served
as commissioner of
Connecticut's Department
of Energy and Environmental Protection,
where he earned a reputation
for fresh thinking
and practical results.
His policy innovations,
he launched many policy innovations,
include the launch of Connecticut's
first-in-the-nation Green
Bank to promote clean energy
using limited public funding
to leverage private capital
and the "LEAN" restructuring
of all of Connecticut's
environmental permitting programs
to make the state's
regulatory framework lighter,
faster, and more efficient
as well as effective.
Prior to taking up his
professorship at Yale in 1994,
he served in a variety of senior positions
at the U.S. EPA where he helped manage
the agency's regulatory programs.
So you can see that he
has had enormous impact
both in the policy realm with action,
as well as intellectual
heft with his ideas.
He's also worked as a senior fellow
at the Peterson Institute
for International Economics
in Washington, D.C.,
where he did breakthrough
work on the links
between trade and environmental issues
and the broader challenges
of globalization.
So before we head into today's talk,
I just wanted to remind
you of two upcoming events,
the next two monthly talks,
just want to briefly advertise them.
The talk for November is going to be
the Mapping as Knowing series.
And for that, the speaker for that,
we managed to snag
the famous science fiction writer, and,
thinker,
author of the "Anthropocene",
Kim Stanley Robinson.
And our December edition of
the Mapping as Knowing talk
is gonna be given by Frank Snowden
who has worked on epidemics.
And so anyway, without further ado, Dan,
we are delighted to have you here
and look forward to hearing from you.
Thank you so much for
accepting our invitation.
- Priya, thank you so
very much for having me.
And special thanks to Ty Kamp
who organized today's program,
and to Barbara Franke who
makes this all possible.
So I'm grateful.
And really thank you to all
of you who are taking time out
of your busy day to be
part of this program today.
I'm gonna present for a bit
but very much hope to move
to a conversation and a
back and forth dialogue,
in the not too far future.
So let me start by saying that
it's just a great pleasure
to have a chance to talk about
this "Better Planet" book,
especially in the week that
it comes out in paperback.
I hadn't planned it this
way but it's great timing.
And for those who are
interested there is in the chat
a brochure with a discount coupon.
So if anyone finds themselves
motivated to go out
and buy the book, Yale University Press
will make it worth your
while with the coupon.
So they're in fact,
I think two of the brochures of the book,
one of them has a coupon attached.
Now I wanna start by saying
that it's actually a
incredibly interesting moment
and one might even say a critical
moment for the discussion
that I wanna have about
a sustainable future,
including climate change,
but also addressing a
broader set of issues.
And I say that, not just because
we're sitting here on the East
Coast, at least some of us
while the West Coast is on fire,
California has been burning.
But we've also seen hurricanes pylon
one on top of another into the Gulf Coast.
Both of these elements of climatic danger
are I think signals,
not necessarily of any
specific climate change
we can link up in a very
tight causal connection,
but in the kind of world
that climate scientists
tell us we should anticipate
in the years ahead.
And I do think the
threat of climate change,
and the broader challenge
to sustainability
is become more and more evident.
It's become a question in
our political dialogue.
Certainly in the election campaign,
these issues are playing a
much more prominent role.
But I really actually wanna
say that what's special
about the moment from my point of view,
is that we are about to
shift gears as a nation.
Next month, we shift maybe not in the day
after the election but by the
end of November, I'm hopeful
that we shift from all
politics all the time,
to questions of policy.
And that's where this
book really has its place.
It is, as you heard, subtitled,
"40 Big Ideas for a Sustainable Future".
It is a volume that I edited,
but represents 56 different
authors in these 40 essays,
offering up a range of perspectives,
from a range of political starting points,
on a range of underlying disciplines,
including some folks who are practitioners
and not academics, but all
offer interesting perspectives
on critical issues, and
thoughtful, carefully constructed,
analytically rigorous pathways forward.
And that's what I'm actually very excited
to dig into a bit today.
The book is, by the way
from Yale University Press.
A great partnership
with the longtime editor
there who's done science and environment,
Jean Thomson Black.
So really just a huge pleasure
to have been able to work with her
and to bring this volume to
publication in record time.
And it grows out of an effort
that the environment school
by the way, those who have been following
him for a long time may not
have kept up with the fact
that the Yale School of Forestry
and Environmental Studies
has rebranded itself as
of a couple of months ago
as the Yale School of the Environment.
And the new dean a few
years ago, Indy Burke
launched the school on an effort
to rethink its direction
and strategic plan.
And one of the things that
emerged was a commitment
to be more of a convening platform
to bring people together to
talk about sustainability
and how to get to a sustainable future.
And this book really grows
out of that broader dialogue,
the Yale environmental
dialogue, as we call it,
organized by Dean Indy Burke,
and now kind of a core part
of the school's program.
And the book itself offers
a range of concepts and principles
for thinking about
environmental challenges,
and related clean energy
questions, land use issues,
natural resource management,
so the full spectrum of
sustainability issues.
It offers frameworks, it
looks at technologies,
it looks at pathways and strategies.
So it really is an interesting
compilation of ideas.
By the way, it represents
a number of authors
from within the school of the environment,
others from across the
Yale campus more broadly,
some number of alums as well.
And three essays are written by students
who were able to win the
chance to be in the book
based on a very competitive process.
So let me offer you some thoughts.
And I wanna start by saying
that the idea of my chapter
is that we need to imagine
a different way of thinking
about the environment in the 21st century
from what we did in the 20th century.
So that's the core
hypothesis I'm introducing.
That what we did in the past,
particularly as we launched the modern era
of environmental protection
in the United States,
in the 1970s and in the
1980s, worked at the time,
served the purpose of that era,
but it's not serving us so well today,
and that what we really
need is a fresh approach,
a new approach that advances our strategy
and gives us a more clear
path to a sustainable future.
My essay in the book is called
"Red Lights to Green Lights:
Toward an Incentive Oriented
Sustainability Strategy".
And a greater focus on incentives,
on how we change behavior,
change company behavior,
particularly the big
polluting industry behavior.
But how we change individual
choices and behavior
is really, I think, a fundamental
issue and a real concern
that needs to be a focus
in environmental policy.
So that's my own essay.
But I'm also building on a
need for better incentives
to engage people in delivering
the results we need.
More use of information
and information technology,
which of course wasn't
available in the same way
in the 20th century
when our modern efforts
in environmental protection were launched.
I also, having spent a lot
of time trying to understand
what's worked and what hasn't
over the last 50 years,
believe that we need to put
much more focus on investment,
how we flow money to solve
environmental problems
and put us toward a sustainable future.
I think we underattended to
that problem in the 1970s, '80s.
Somehow there was an idea
that if the law was framed,
the money would follow,
turned out not to be true.
I also think there is a need
to focus on integration,
on a more systems-oriented approach,
we might call it a more
ecological approach
to these problems.
And I'm gonna dig in on all of this,
over the course of the
next 20 minutes or so,
as I lay out my argument for why we need
a 21st century approach to
environmental protection,
and how this "Better
Planet" book sketches,
not only in my essay,
but in all the essays,
some of the elements of
what that might look like.
So first of all, I wanna be
clear that I'm not saying
that the 20th century strategy
of environmental protection was a failure.
Quite to the contrary, we
have better quality air,
now much better quality rivers.
For those who pick up the book,
you'll see that the introductory chapter,
I note that I grew up along
the Naugatuck River in
Northwestern Connecticut.
And that river used to
flow orange and purple,
depending on the colors
of the unit oil factory
that was dumping its waste into the river.
The river is much cleaner today,
it's swimmable, there's fish in it.
So we have made huge
progress as a society.
But I do think they're important questions
about how we continue to
make progress and address
the residual problems that
continue to plague us.
And that's where my argument focuses
on the need for innovation.
My belief is we've gotten a good distance
with a certain set of strategies,
but to go where we need to
go over the coming years,
we need new ideas, new
approaches, new technologies
to be brought into the
sustainability world.
And my basic claim is that
the 20th century approach
to environmental protection
was largely around telling
people, particularly the
business world, what not to do.
So putting up a red light, a
stop sign saying don't do that,
don't pollute, can't go there.
And that sort of red light strategy
did change behavior in some regards
but it was not very
good at getting business
to become solutions providers.
So we don't have a
transformed energy foundation
for our society compared to
what we thought we might have
in the way of transformation
over the past 50 years.
So I wanna argue that we should have,
just as we have at any intersection,
not just red lights that
tell people when to stop,
but green lights that
tell people when to go,
we need the same framework of
green lights as a complement
to red lights in environmental regulation.
And what I mean really is
that we need incentives,
we need to get people
who have the capacity
to solve problems, to
step up to those issues,
to become solutions providers.
And I think my argument is that
we need to really structure
incentives to flow society's resources
towards those solutions providers.
And frankly, to steer
money away from companies
that are cause of problems
and are not moving us
towards a sustainable future.
So here's the issues that I see us
potentially being able to step up to.
First, I think there is a value
in making people pay
for the harm they cause.
So the biggest green light is
to have those who are doing
things in a clean way,
not polluting, not pay
and that's a signal of strong
value in the business world.
So again, my number one
green light is price signals.
And that would tell us
if you're doing things the
right way, you don't pay,
if you're a polluter, you're
gonna pay for every increment
of harm you're putting out into society.
And this is best done if we switch
from the 20th century approach
to environmental protection.
It was largely what we in the business
call command and control regulation
largely around government
mandates that you can't exceed
a certain level of pollution,
but everyone was allowed
to pollute up to that level for free.
My argument is nothing for free anymore.
Either you stop your harm, no pollution,
in which case you don't have to pay.
But if you're continuing to pollute,
you're gonna pay for
every incremental harm
up to the limit beyond
which it's forbidden.
And so that's the core
idea of a price signal.
By the way, in the "Better
Planet" book, Bill Nordhaus,
our prize winning,
Nobel Memorial Prize
Winning Economics colleague
lays out the case for price signals
as the core of the response
to climate change and I agree.
Now more broadly, my argument
is that we should really seek to,
and this is the radical
part of the agenda,
Priya promised that I'm
working on some radical ideas.
The big one is that we should
really be committed to ending
what economists would call externalities.
Smoke up a smokestack,
effluent out of pipeline,
any kind of spillover
of harm from an industry
or from an individual
onto society more broadly.
So I think every company should pay
for its emissions out the smokestack,
every one of us should
pay for the car exhaust
at the back of our car.
And I think it was not possible to do
this in the 20th century,
because it was much too
complicated to keep track of.
But our information age makes
that tracking of pollution
and the pricing of harms
and the passing out of pollution bills,
really not a very
difficult exercise at all.
And that again, if we make
people pay for the harm
they're causing or stop what they're doing
that's causing that problem,
that internalizes the externality,
make sure that no one
is getting the benefit
of putting harms out
onto society for free.
By the way, this will
change some business models
dramatically, because
there are some companies
that couldn't survive, except for the fact
they are privatizing the
gains of their activities,
the products they sell, but
externalizing the costs.
Putting at least in part, those burdens,
whether in the form of
pollution or something else
on to the community, on to
the society more generally.
So I am arguing
that we need a new
Environmental Protection Agency,
not spending its time with
engineers figuring out
what the best available technology is
and that's the core of our current law,
and ordering various industries to apply
a certain smokestack scrubber
or other piece of
pollution control equipment
onto their factory activity,
but rather to have an EPA
focused on measuring harm,
putting a price on it, by
calculating how much risk
and epidemiological or
ecological harm is being caused,
and then sending out the bills,
making people pay for what they're doing.
I think that kind of a structure creates,
again, a big incentive
to control pollution.
So every factory would
have a big incentive
to reduce its harm, but also
to entrepreneurs and innovators
to provide new approaches to doing
all the things we need to do,
that will be much lower emissions.
They will be the ones to
bring to the factories
ways to cut their harm
and therefore cut their pollution bills.
So I think what it does is
it incentivizes innovation,
and drives people to
become solutions providers.
Now, again, as I said, this
connects in a number of ways
to some of the other essays
that are in this book.
Ken Gillingham, my colleague
in the environment school,
one of the rising star, young
environmental economists,
also makes a big argument
around the importance of innovation.
So I'm excited that his essay lines up
so nicely with my own.
And of course, as I mentioned,
Bill Nordhaus, the same thing.
He's making an argument
around the importance
of a policy framework that
puts a price on causing harm.
And his central focus, as I mentioned,
is on a carbon charge, making
people pay for the greenhouse
gas emissions that are
contributing to climate change.
But there are a lot of other ideas
that I wanna just mention.
And I guess, I wanna pause and say
that both the Ken Gillingham idea
and the Bill Nordhaus idea,
are aimed not only at
changing the behavior
of the polluter, but also inspiring others
to help polluters stop polluting.
So it's really about not
just incentivizing more care
with the production activities of society,
but also to spur innovation and investment
in energy efficiency, in
clean energy technology,
in renewable power generation.
So again, if that is what can be done
without paying a price,
there will be a relative price
signal to steer people away
from fossil fuel burning
towards these new cleaner,
more renewable technologies.
Another source of green
lights can be information.
So another part of the 21st
century sustainability strategy
that I wanna sketch out
for you is how we use
data and information and the
capacity to get our hands
on that information, manage it,
and make it actionable
with information technology
in ways that were unimaginable
a couple of decades ago.
And in our "Better Planet"
book are several essays
that talk about how to do
this in one way or another.
One of the areas that I've been working
on through the Yale Initiative
on Sustainable Finance,
which I co-direct
with my school of management
colleague, Todd Cort,
is centered on better metrics
of corporate sustainability performance.
So asking companies to give us
more data on their environmental,
social and governance
performance in the marketplace.
And that is talked about
in the investment world
by its acronym, ESG reporting.
And right now, some companies report
but the data is not very good.
A lot of its backward
looking not forward looking,
a lot of its narrowly focused on risk
and not always focused on
who's a solutions provider,
therefore, upside opportunities,
as well as some of the downside burdens
the company is causing.
A lot of it is very focused on reputation,
rather than operational success.
So there's a lot of problems
with an existing framework.
So Todd and I have been
arguing in his essay
in the "Better Planet" book makes clear
that we would benefit as a
society from better metrics,
better data on corporate performance.
Really trying to understand
who the corporate
sustainability leaders are,
and hold them up as a place
that investors might wanna go
and what we have found is
that an ever larger number
of investors are sustainability minded.
They want better alignment
between their values,
and where their portfolios
are putting their money.
So this idea of better ESG metrics
is very much what they
need to make this desire
for an alignment between their values
and their portfolio come together.
So I think that's a great example
of where better data
investment and information
and in this case specifically
in a next generation of ESG
metrics is going to be essential.
Now, of course, some of its
still will be risk-oriented.
And from a climate change point of view,
knowing which companies are
as we now say, carbon exposed,
likely to be suffering more consequences
than their competitors or those companies
that are in other industries
will be of real value.
And in particular, companies
holding fossil fuel assets
may find themselves with what
are known as stranded assets;
oil in the ground, natural gas underground
that can't ever be taken advantage of,
because it is become disfavored
as we move to a clean energy future.
But the next generation of
metrics that I wanna see
goes even beyond those
kind of core elements,
the things like which
companies and which industries
and which management
teams of those companies
are positioned to transition
to a decarbonized future?
Because that's what people
would really like to
know in the marketplace.
Looking out ahead 10 or 15 or 20 years,
who is positioned to be
a success in business,
and whose business model may fail,
because it's trapped in
the fossil fuel past?
Now, I think that whole
idea of a different approach
for business of really
trying to understand
who the leaders are from a
sustainability perspective,
dovetails with another of the essays
that I very much like,
the one by Carter Roberts,
who's the head of the World Wildlife Fund.
And he has written about kind of the need
for a new business ethos,
and that actually is capturing
a spirit of the moment.
Suddenly, there's a lot of talk,
that the old business mission of thinking
that the goal is always
to maximize profits,
or to deliver what the
famous University of Chicago
economist once called shareholder primacy,
is giving way to a new business spirit
that focuses on
stakeholder responsibility.
And that means that a business
is not just delivering goods
and profits for its
shareholders, its owners,
but it has some responsibility
to its employees,
to the communities it operates in,
to its customers, to its suppliers.
And I think that argument very
much is what Carter Roberts
is saying in his essay in
this "Better Planet" book.
And I believe that there
is a societal value change
underway that is basically
saying to the business community,
you need to be more broad-minded,
it can't simply be all about profits,
and certainly not about profits,
where you are privatizing
gains, and socializing,
putting on all of us the costs
of things like your pollution.
So better information makes that possible.
We've got a new capacity with data
and information technology to track
who's putting those emissions out.
And again, in my reimagined world,
making those people pay for
the harms they're causing.
Now, it is also the case
that with better data, and tracking,
we can manage a whole set
of other sustainability
or environmental problems better.
And another of the essays
in the "Better Planet" book,
I find really inspiring and
it's a nod to where the future
might go is the one by my
environment school colleague
Marian Chertow on waste management.
And Marian, some of you may
know has been in that arena
for something like 30
years, and has really been
on the front lines of thinking
about how we do recapture
and recycling of materials,
and how we try to minimize waste.
And that's a booming
issue of societal concern,
obviously around things like
plastic, but even more broadly.
And so Marian lays out
with one of her students,
a beautiful argument for
a price based strategy
of waste management,
where you make people pay
for what they throw away,
but allow them to recycle for free.
And she's got a well structured essay
on how it is we might
reimagine waste management
to really ensure that we
get to a more closed loop
use of materials where that
which can be taken back,
recaptured and reused will
be and where we're minimizing
that which goes out forever as waste.
Likewise, there's a great essay
in the book from Tracy Mehan.
And by the way, one of the notable things
about this book is,
these are not essays
from environmentalists,
they're from environmental analysts,
so people who are really
expert in their fields.
And it seeks very much
to have perspectives
that are not all on the left
side of the political spectrum
but include a number of Republicans,
one of whom is Tracy Mehan,
and has written an excellent
essay on water management.
Basically making the
argument we can't afford
to have such a thing as wastewater,
we need to be able to recapture clean
and reuse all of our water supplies.
Absolutely correct.
This is true in general
even more true in a world
where climate change is gonna stress
traditional water flows,
traditional rainfall patterns.
And of course, we're seeing
even in Connecticut this year,
the emergence of a serious drought.
So a great essay on water
as a scarce resource
needing to have a price
on it to incentivize
care and conservation and its management,
and to encourage investments
in the sort of infrastructure
that allows us to be much more
tight in our water systems,
not lose water.
Now, it also is the case that we recognize
that some of the problems
of the past are a function
of people not thinking
about ecological linkages.
And Schmitz has a great essay
on the need to understand
ecosystems in a more holistic way.
Understand the connections
across different aspects
of the plant and animal world.
And I think this provides a very important
science foundation for
this 21st century approach
to environmental protection I'm imagining.
And just adjacent to that
argument that Schmitz presents
is another essay from
authors that have their homes
in the school of the environment,
Paul Anastas, and Julie Zimmerman,
who make the case for
a systems perspective
in environmental law and policy.
An integrated approach,
not a siloed approach,
arguing that the 20th century
was often about managing air,
and water and waste and land
in separate legal structures,
in separate incentive frameworks.
And it hasn't worked out that well,
we misunderstood the connections.
And in some cases, just move pollution
from one form to another.
Most famously, if you put
a scrubber on a smokestack,
and it pulls the soot out of the stack,
now you have a solid waste
and you put it in the land,
now you have a land waste
and then when rainwater
comes through it, it
takes it into a stream,
and now you've turned
it into a water problem.
So that's not a very good approach.
And that's the kind of thing
that Paul Anastas and Julie Zimmerman
are calling out with their
essay aimed at systems thinking,
systems design, and really a
much more holistic approach
to how we produce things, what
kinds of products we produce,
and our framework of law
and policy in response.
Similarly, Jane Lubchenco,
who's written a beautiful essay on oceans,
tells us that we need to get
beyond our past framework
that the ocean was too big,
and it wouldn't ever be polluted by us
'cause we couldn't affect
it 'cause it was so vast,
to the more recent view
that the ocean is doomed,
that it's full of plastic
and hopeless to her argument,
that the ocean is central,
fundamental to life on earth, and
is too big not to fix.
So that is, I think, a
beautiful perspective.
But her secondary argument
is that we have to understand
that we have people in our ecosystems,
people affect the ocean, and
we needed to manage the ocean,
and the people that live on the planet
in a more integrated way,
understanding trade offs,
and recognizing the need
for the ocean to work
as an ecosystem, but also for people.
And again, it's a systems perspective
played out in one particular venue.
A fabulous essay from Sue
Biniaz, who was for many years
on the State Department's
climate change team,
the lead environmental lawyer
in the State Department,
she has a similar argument when
it comes to climate change.
That you can't rely on
the Paris climate change
agreement of 2015 to do
all the work we need to do.
We've gotta bring others whose behavior,
whose incentive structure
shapes choices that determine
whether we have a lot of
greenhouse gases or not.
So she would argue in
the international domain,
yes, we have a Framework
Convention on Climate Change
with a staff that works on it
but we need to pull in the
World Trade Organization
and the World Bank,
and the International Labor Organization,
all to be part of a
unified effort to respond
to the sustainability challenge broadly
to climate change in particular.
Another area where I think
we've got work to do is on investment.
As I mentioned, one of
the critical shortfalls
of the 20th century was
not paying attention
where the money would come from
to create a sustainable future
to invest in the infrastructure
that we would need,
clean energy infrastructure and more.
Larry Seltzer, who runs
the the Conservation Fund,
another environmental group,
makes a very interesting argument
that if we are gonna get land conservation
done at the scale we
need, and Tom Lovejoy,
in yet another essay tells us
that biodiversity requires us
to be much more protective of
a much wider swath of land.
Well, Larry Seltzer's piece
of the story is to say,
governments will never do enough,
we need to make sure that
there is private capital
being deployed to be part of
our land conservation effort.
And he talks about land trusts
and other ways of bringing
private funds into our
land conservation agenda,
and really effectively a new
model for how we're going to do
the scale of habitat protection required
for a thriving human population
as well as plant and animal life.
Another of the essays that I
think is really interesting
or several of the essays relate
to the need for new
approaches to communications.
Tony Leiserowitz in particular
from our Yale Climate Change
Communications project,
lays out a very interesting set of views
about how Americans see the
problem of climate change,
what motivates them to take action,
even what words resonate with people.
And I think understanding
how to communicate science
to the policy arena is again,
a terrible breakdown of the
past and something we need
to get much better about
going forward into the future.
And that brings me to one final essay
that I just wanna mention.
And in a book with 40 essays
that I'm the editor of,
I'm not allowed to have a favorite,
just as no parent can
have a favorite child.
But I do wanna say, the
essay by Thomas Easley
has resonated in a very big and broad way.
His piece is called "Hip
Hop Sustainability".
And it reflects his reality of being
a dean in the school of the environment,
but also as a hip hop artist.
And the case he makes is for bringing
the discussion around sustainability,
and including climate
change, in particular,
to communities that have been
left out of the conversation.
In his case, the black community,
the inner city community,
the world that he talks
to in his hip hop music.
And his argument is that
if you can speak to people
in their own terms, in
their own way of approaching
a problem, they're much
more likely to engage.
And he is, of course, correct.
So his ability to broaden
the discussion bring people
into a political dialogue
that they didn't know
they had an important
reason to be part of,
is I think quite stunning.
So let me close just by
saying a few more visions
of the 21st century strategy
for a sustainable future
that the "Better Planet" book lays out.
We had a very top down approach
to policy in the 20th century,
we need to have some top down
priorities and targets set
but with bottom up implementation,
recognizing not all the work will be done
by the federal government,
some will be done
at the state level,
some at the local level.
And oh, by the way, some will be done
at the global level over at all.
We do have the opportunity
to build on information
technologies that weren't
available in the past century.
We do have enormous
potential to bring data
and data tracking technologies
to bear to give us new tools
and new possibilities
for how to limit harm,
particularly the idea of
tracing and tracking emissions
and putting a price on those.
And frankly, I would argue
that the environmental arena
is curiously unaffected up till now,
by the entire revolution
of information technology.
No other arena of society
that I'm aware of has done
so little to bring information
technology to bear.
You know, no baseball
team today picks players
the way they might have 30 years ago,
when a scout would be
chewing tobacco and saying,
well, that guy has good
stuff and this guy doesn't.
Now they're data-driven.
They now measure how hard
people hit, how fast they run,
how quickly they jump.
So it's a data-driven
world and that same spirit
just hasn't been deeply embedded
into the environmental world yet
but there is a potential to do it now.
As I said, we're gonna need to move away
from government mandates as the core
of our regulatory framework to
government pricing of harms,
letting people be flexible
in what they choose to do about that,
but pay fully for every bit
of harm they're causing.
And again, a more integrated
world where we're thinking
in a unified way, an
ecological way about problems.
Recognizing connections and trade offs,
and try to be more coherent
in how we manage that.
And, as I said, it's a world
that needs more innovation.
To get to a much cleaner future,
we can't rely on the tools of the past,
the frameworks of the past,
the incentives of the past,
we need to move forward.
And I do think that the
core of the argument
should be this new value,
foundational value,
that takes the right of
breathers ever more seriously.
So I don't think it's the
case that society doesn't care
who has the underlying
environmental rights,
I think we need to lodge with all of us
the right to a clean environment,
to make environmental justice
a more central part of
our policy framework.
And with that, I would argue
we have a new principle
that commits to an end of externalities.
Every polluter either
stops their harm causing
or pays fully.
So that's a lot to lay on the table.
I invite now questions and comments.
I'm often asked whether
I see a promising path,
whether I'm an optimist,
or whether I think all the
shower of bad news makes
me a pessimist and my answer is,
I am somewhat pessimistic
in the short term,
but in the long term,
I think there's lots of opportunities
and as this book demonstrates,
lots of paths forward.
So with that, let me stop
and invite your questions,
your comments, your pushback
and let's have a dialogue.
- Thank you so much, Dan,
for this wonderful talk and,
please feel free to start typing up
your questions in the chat.
Ty has kindly offered to moderate
and help us handle the questions.
And if I may use my
provocative as the organizer
to ask the first question.
So Dan,
I see that you are optimistic
at the policy level
in terms of the interventions
that can be done
and that will be very, very effective.
I was just wondering
whether you are optimistic
in terms of at the individual level,
because we are seeing a
rampant denialism of science,
of climate change.
So, how do we change people's minds
about being more open and
sort of accepting of the facts
that are unrolling in front of our eyes?
Yeah, and the connected
question is, do you see
young activists like Greta Thunberg
actually playing an
important role going forward?
How do you see the sort
of the activism side
of that movement as well?
Thank you.
- So Priya, you've raised one
of the most depressing and,
"could be pessimism inducing
aspects of our current moment,"
which is, how many people
seem uninterested in science,
in data, in rational analysis,
in having policy grounded, in
facts, and empirical analysis?
So it really, it could be a
source of enormous distress.
And I am actually distressed by that.
I think, however, that the
lesson of our COVID-19 moment,
may well be that if you don't
pay attention to all of that,
you suffer.
And it's not that somebody else suffers,
you will suffer, your family will suffer.
And there are kind of straightforward ways
to put your risk into
a much lower category
by wearing a mask and social distancing.
And that the people who are doing that
are having a better outcome
than people who are not.
And, of course, there's bad luck people
that were behaving properly
that still get the disease
and risky behavior folks who don't.
But over the broad scope of society,
I think it's gonna appear
very clear that the people
who are following science,
following data are gonna come out better.
But I am stunned at our
current political moment
where so many people still,
even if they have faced
personal challenges,
don't seem to act in their public life,
in their political life,
with regard to that very
straightforward logic.
So I think it is worrisome.
I do think that we have activists
who are starting to sharpen our thinking.
And Greta gets great credit
for having raised the
profile of climate change.
Her school strikes, I
think, have motivated
lots of young people to
think this can't be left
to the folks who are of my
generation, your generation
to solve the problem, we
haven't yet gotten there.
And the young folks I think are willing
to be more creative to try new things.
But I do think, and I don't know
whether this is put on Greta specifically,
but I do think there is also
some challenges for the young.
And I see this, you know,
in in many contexts,
but there are trade offs.
One of the reasons we still
have a pandemic debate on
is because it is
a terrible thing that
people have lost their jobs.
So there is an economic counterpoint
to that pandemic that is real
and people have suffered
really serious life losses
because of lost jobs,
lost economic security.
So I think the fact is that those who care
about the environment have to
acknowledge that most people
also care about their
family's economic security,
the ability to have a job.
So how do you balance
jobs in the environment
it's gotta be taken more seriously.
And in that regard, you know, Priya,
I'm gonna end with your question
'cause I think it's the right one.
I think the answer is data
and science and good analysis,
that's how you do balancing,
that's how you make trade offs.
And I don't see any other path forward
but to dig deeper into the science
and have it emerge even
more fully and forcefully
as the foundation for our decision making.
- Thank you very much.
- [Ty] A question I
think from Mrs. Franke.
- Oh, thank you.
To follow up with Thomas
Easley's thoughts.
Incidentally, his last
name and mine are the same.
My maiden name is Easley, so.
Has any work been done
to help with education
as far as primary and secondary
schools are concerned?
I know it is an area where our hope may be
if they are are educated
along the lines that you're proposing.
- So I would tell you
that I'm almost everyone
who's thought long and hard
about what it's gonna take
to get to a sustainable
future sees education,
and, frankly, in generational shifts
in underlying understanding
and values as foundational.
And I think this is true
in some arenas that we know
already and can see the evidence.
The world of recycling didn't exist
when you and I were young,
we had to be retrained
and we're still not
always probably as good
as the younger folks.
I have to admit to occasionally
throwing a beer can
in the trash and not in the recycling bin.
Now, my children just think that's absurd.
They would never imagine
throwing away a good aluminum can
that's ready for repurposing
as a new aluminum can.
So that's an element of
retraining and of education,
where the young have got
it clear in their minds,
they don't even have to think about it,
where some of us are
still slow on the draw.
So I do think, better
environmental education
beginning at the earliest grades,
deepening the understanding
of science as the foundation
is gonna be quite fundamental
to success on all of this.
- Dan, a question from the chat,
we have a couple of piled up.
Someone says thanks for raising the issue
of incorporating externalities
in our economic analysis.
How do you suggest that might occur?
- So I think there are
several ways to do this.
Again, I'm a big believer in
bringing a much richer base
of data and analytics
to environmental policy.
So I would like to have people report
more fully on their environmental impacts.
I think we should require
companies to provide metrics
that tell us how much in the way
of greenhouse gases they're emitting?
What kind of harm they're
putting out their effluent pipe
into the rivers and streams nearby?
What they're putting up a smokestack
beyond greenhouse gases that
might be of societal concern?
And with that data, one can
begin to put a number on it.
That's why I'm saying we
need to recast our EPA
away from the engineers of the past,
and toward epidemiologists, ecologists,
risk analysts and economists,
who will do that work of putting a number
on the externalities and
then sending out the bills,
making people pay for
the harm they're causing.
And by the way, some people
think that sounds quite radical,
it's actually not.
This has been the core
of environmental efforts
over 400 years, which basically said,
going back to some of the
earliest nuisance cases,
in British law 400 years ago
on which American law builds,
the most famous case is called Eldridge.
And in that case, a pig farmer was told
you can't have your smelly pigs
polluting the neighborhood,
stinking up the neighborhood,
either get rid of your pig, stop the harm,
or you're gonna have to pay your neighbors
for the harm you're causing.
So this idea of ending externalities,
making people pay for
their harm is 400 years old
in our Anglo-American Legal Tradition.
- Many companies are producing ESG goals
spontaneously from within the organization
but U.S. fossil fuel companies
are singularly refractory
to such endeavors, how can
they be brought around?
- So I actually am not very optimistic
about voluntary environmental,
social, governance reporting.
I think there's a problem,
never mind in the fossil fuel industry
but broadly that companies tend to report
on their own terms and without regard
to the need for comparability
across the data,
one company to the next.
So I'm in favor of having
our Securities and Exchange Commission
establish a core set of
sustainability metrics, again,
in the environment, social
and governance categories,
that would be required
alongside of financial data
as part of quarterly and
annually corporate reports,
as providing the foundational information
that the stock market needs
so that people can understand
who's in a good position, who's not.
And frankly, it should gauge
those who are providing
solutions to the market
so that we can say that's a company
that may be a winner over time,
as well as those who are causing harms
or holding assets that are a problem,
holding fossil fuel assets, for example.
So I do think a framework,
a government structure
of sustainability metrics
is probably the way to go.
And that would, of course,
apply first and foremost,
to the fossil fuel companies
that would then have to tell us
what their risks are, and
whether they're counting
on getting out all these
fossil fuels they hold
for their future success.
- Thank you.
Another question,
there are some consequences
to removing fossil fuels.
The LWCF just got full funding
in the Great American Outdoors Act
but it is funded by royalties
from oil and gas exploration
in the North Sea.
Won't they have less money
to pay their royalties going forward?
- Yes and in fact, that
might be an argument in,
some might push back on my entire pay
for your externalities line of reasoning,
because the goal over time is
actually not to have people
pay, it's to have people stop polluting.
And likewise, to the extent that royalties
from fossil fuel
exploitation are what fund
that land and water account,
we probably over time
have to plan for a day when
those numbers begin to dwindle,
because the amount of
fossil fuels being extracted
is going dramatically down.
- Okay.
Please, could you explain
more about the metrics
that companies need to
have to achieve SDG?
For example, B Lab provides some tools,
but maybe there are more
that can be built in the near future.
- So this raises another very good point.
And let me just back up in case
not everyone's familiar
with the SDG reference.
But in addition, in 2015,
to having the Paris
climate change agreement,
the UN put forward something
called the Sustainable Development Goals.
17 different goals that represent
really not just challenges of environment,
but many other issues,
including ending poverty,
ending hunger, moving
towards clean energy,
providing better public health,
all of which are underpinned by metrics.
So there's 169 targets that have been set,
that these goals are
meant to drive countries
towards addressing over
the 15 years to 2030.
So I do think there's a
lot of work being done
on measuring Sustainable
Development Goals.
And a good number of companies,
I would say many companies
that are serious about their
sustainability strategies
are trying to translate
some of those goals
into their own corporate
reporting framework.
So they're putting
together a corporate report
on some of the goals that
they think are most relevant
to their own business,
to their own industry,
and putting that information
out to the world.
It may well be that as part
of the government mandated ESG disclosure,
ESG reporting that I would like to see
that a core set of those
Sustainable Development Goals
would be among the things required.
- Okay, thank you.
Comments here, the call for bottom up
or top down is still too anthropocentric,
this is a recipe for collapse,"
one of our participants suggests.
we need to transcend this
vocabulary and these metaphors.
He followed up a bit later with this,
more data and greater amounts
of science are not enough.
We need to change the
fundamental metaphors
our culture is working with.
And he mentions, the fatal consequences
of a misplaced metaphor in
the agricultural industry.
- So first of all, I do think
how you frame things matters.
And again, several of the essays
in the "Better Planet"
book make that point.
Jane Lubchenco's essay on the oceans
is all about a new
narrative for the oceans.
Tony Leiserowitz's work on climate change
is all about how you frame
the issue in a manner
that engages more people and brings
them into the conversation,
gets them to take the
issue more seriously.
I think that the challenge
that the questioner
is presenting, is that it's
very, very difficult to deliver
such a radical change of perspectives
that people are going beyond
their own human interest
to really focus as much as
maybe we would like them to
on biodiversity, on the world of nature
as an equally important priority.
And, my own experience in the policy arena
is that it's an in fact a
failing cause to try to hope
that everyone's gonna be high-minded,
and take nature as
seriously as human life.
So instead, I believe that the best hope
is to frame the agenda around
how nature supports people,
and that we need to protect biodiversity
and support the ocean,
because in part, at least,
it is essential for our own human success.
- Thank you.
Please, could you elaborate more
about environmental justice,
especially because nowadays,
there is an increased
role of climate litigation
in advancing and undermining
climate change action.
- So I do think at the core of my vision
for a 21st century approach
to environmental prediction
is this idea of not
permitting any externalities.
That is to say at least
no pollution for free.
There may be some
unavoidable level of of harm
that's gonna be emitted, but
it should all be fully paid for
at rates that will provide
ongoing deterrence and encourage
people to continue to move
away from harm causing.
And I do think more broadly,
that what is now often talked
about as climate justice
beyond environmental justice
is suggesting that it's unfair
to a number of communities
to have the risk of climate change rising.
And I like to say that climate change
is particularly challenging,
because the vectors of responsibility
are even more complicated
than with most issues,
which is to say, greenhouse gas
emissions blanket the earth,
so there is a geographic
spread of enormous scale.
No one country can
solve the problem alone.
Even if the United States
entirely counter factually
were to stop all emissions tomorrow,
it would only take 15% of the emissions
at the global scale out of the system,
we'd still have 85% remaining.
So it can only be addressed in
a collective global approach.
And furthermore, from a point
of view of climate justice,
there is not only a spatial
spread that's enormous,
but across time, a temporal spread.
And a lot of the harm
that's being done is to,
not anyone is alive
today, but our children,
our grandchildren, and their
children and grandchildren.
So there is a profound intergenerational
equity dimension here as well.
So I do think environmental
justice is a big topic
along several different lines, including
a more immediate harm
spilled from factories
onto adjacent communities,
often communities
that are disadvantaged,
communities of color,
and then these various vectors of justice
related to the climate change problem.
So lots to work through.
And much of it's been under
attended to in the past
kind of environmental discussions
and environmental policy
frameworks that have been in place.
- Okay, I hope I'm not missing
the beginning part of this question.
Wouldn't this additional layer
of sustainability metrics
result in another level
of corporate governance
and middle management?
- No, I think the requirement
that companies report
on the environment is
something that most companies
of any scale are doing already,
they're just not doing it
in a coherent cross company,
cross industry, comparable way.
So I think it could, in fact,
be simplifying for companies
to have a single reporting framework
defined by the government.
Right now, there's a dozen
different private sector groups
out there in the data
analytics world trying
to collect this data, sending out surveys,
pushing companies to
respond to their survey,
and as a result, there's a
scramble within companies
to keep up with all these requests.
So a single unified government
structure would I think,
actually cut the amount of
time and effort required,
and improve the quality and
comparability of the data
in a way that would benefit
maybe not every company,
but certainly all the investors
who want that framework of
comparable, high quality,
high integrity data that
they can actually trust
and would view as a foundation
for making investment decisions.
- Okay.
Continued comment from
one of the participants.
"We now need to move beyond
the major universities
and change public discourse in culture.
Other Rhodes scholars
have been working on this for a while.
And he suggests, "I guess
you're familiar with them."
- So what is the question there?
- I guess just the comment
about moving beyond the major universities
and changing public discourse,
maybe more of just a common.
- I think there is obviously a
case to have the conversation
carried beyond universities to be taken
into the public domain,
into the political arena.
I think, again, as I mentioned earlier,
what's notable about this
year's presidential election
is the degree to which
environment broadly,
but climate change in particular,
has been part of the debate,
much more so in the past.
And I do think, again, we can credit
some of the younger activists
for having driven the agenda,
and for having ensured that the candidates
really in both parties
are having to step up
and answer questions.
And I think that's given
the public as clear a signal
and as sharply defined a
choice on that set of issues
as we have seen in any recent election.
- Thank you.
I think we've covered the questions
that have been submitted thus far.
I'm just checking for any new ones,
but I think that's pretty much it.
- Good.
Well, it's been a pleasure to
be part of this conversation.
I thank Priya and the entire
team at the Franke center
for the opportunity to be
with you today and to
have this discussion.
And hope some of you will carry
it forward in your own way
and in your own settings in
the weeks and months ahead.
- Thank you so much Dan for speaking
and for an absolutely wonderful talk.
- Well, it's a pleasure
and I wish you all well
as you think about how to advance
this sustainability agenda
from your own starting points.